[Musique]
l'ampleur des dégâts ne laisse aucun
doute les pluies torrentielles qui se
sont abattues sur le kentucky ont été
impitoyables les morts se comptent déjà
par dizaines parmi eux ses quatre
enfants âgés de 2 à 8 ans et le bilan
pourrait s'alourdir considérablement
des centaines de personnes sont toujours
portées disparues dit le gouverneur de
l'état retrouvez toutes les victimes
pourraient prendre des mois
de 20 à 27 centimètres de pluie sont
tombés sur l'est du kentucky en 48
heures la semaine dernière provoquant
des inondations sans précédent dans le
secteur plusieurs ont dû quitter leur
maison rapidement
nous avons tous perdu 17 sinistres et
tout ce que nous avons fait les
vêtements que nous portions quand nous
sommes partis ajoute celle ci quelques
centaines de personnes sont hébergées
dans des refuges les autorités étant de
fournir de l'eau et de la nourriture à
ceux qui en ont besoin des ponts et des
routes sont endommagées des communautés
ont perdu l'eau courante et
l'électricité
nous avons besoin des deux dans ce
résident et pour ajouter au malheur on
prévoit encore de la pluie dans les
prochaines heures
ce qui pourrait aggraver la situation
pendant ce temps c'est le feu qu'on doit
combattre en californie le brasier le
plus destructeur depuis le début de
l'année fait présentement rage près de
la frontière de l'orégon il a détruit
plus de 20 mille hectares de forêt et
fait au moins deux morts
au moins 2000 personnes ont dû être
évacuées dans le secteur des refuges ont
été mis sur pied pour les accueillir
je n'ai plus de maison plus de meubles
plus de vêtements dit cette dame
avec les températures qui grimpe et la
sécheresse qui s'aggrave
la californie est plus vulnérable que
jamais aux feux de forêt depuis que l'on
tient des statistiques les années 2020
et 2021 sont les plus dévastatrices
centaine d'hectares brûlés ici olivier
bâche un réseau canada montréal